I'm hopeful vice with Bobby kalila and
Stevie Bonjour my name is Brandon I'm a
23 year old and I live in Central
Washington I think my numerate my new
roommate wants to have sex with me
I just moved back from Thailand after
living there for eight months and I
found a place with an old co-worker the
guy that owns the house is in his
mid-40s and saying he is not
entertaining is an understatement every
time I'm in the kitchen he will come out
from the basement wearing his pajamas
and every time he has a massive boner he
once told me that he'd rather pay his
boys to keep him company rather than a
female sex worker what do I do
think wait wait is this person I think
it took so it's a 23 23 year-old male he
has a new roommate who's a 40 year old
man and he [ __ ] what's the wrong we
just say hey dude put your dick away man
because you don't want that when you're
making a grilled cheese sandwich at like
1:00 in the morning
you're [ __ ] roommates dick did you
say dude put your dick away yeah but
just at the thought that he could be
jerking off in the other room and
thinking about you is right Steve you
have a new roommate he's a 40 year old
he's a 58 year old guy with a bulge
massive bullocks ah we'd have a time the
four year old guy all right so just all
right you're making a sandwich
listen Troy no no let me talk to you
first I'll be Troy yeah okay can you
make me a sandwich listen man yeah you
can't be doing that around here I own
this house what do you mean you live in
my house it's just inappropriate are you
making me uncomfortable okay but what
all I'm asking is to clothe yourself man
I know I have my pajamas on and I see
your penis but you know it's but yeah
but my pant I can't help that I have a
hard-on right now when I look at you it
makes me uncomfortable I'm just letting
know that looking at you makes me feel
uncomfortable because I just want to nut
in your mouth yeah and but I can't do it
legally we have a severe problem we
don't because I'm never gonna know your
mouth but it doesn't matter you're
making me very uncomfortable
if you don't do anything about I'm
moving out okay or here I'm gonna have
to all right I'm gonna go change I'm
gonna go check you I come back with
jeans all right I'll come
strongly that sandwich I'll make you a
grilled cheese sandwich but yeah just
get my jeans close yeah I have my jean
that you see I'm wearing my own all
right we're good my hunting jacket right
jacket on and my jeans
we're good but kind of let you know
right now yeah I live with you so right
now all right I'll pay my rent I have a
pond right I have all the stuff on Yeah
right can you still make me the sandwich
I'll make you sandwich I just I don't
hey Steve yeah please don't say anything
derogatory I'm gonna let you know right
now I don't have a hard-on
Bobby wink Terry oh I wish okay I don't
I don't have a hard-on you're gonna have
to move around when I have to move well
it's my house so I guess your move yeah
there's the advice there it is give you
a full-on scenario a whole scenario
right there
there you go Brandon very helpful
[Music]